le département de la réunion aux côtés
des réunionnais devenir assistant
familial
l'assistant familial est un agent non
titulaire de la collectivité
départementale
il a pour rôle principal d'offrir à un
enfant séparé de sa famille les
conditions de vie lui permettant de
poursuivre son développement physique
psychique affectif et sa socialisation
et puis accueillir au sein de sa famille
des jeunes confiés par le département au
titre de l'aide sociale à l'enfance pour
accueillir ces jeunes au sein de sa
famille l'assistant familial doit
obtenir un agrément délivré par le
président du conseil départemental
comment devenir assistant familial si
vous êtes à l'écouté disponible et
souhaitait aider des enfants en
difficulté vous êtes désireux de devenir
assistant familial
contacté le service de la protection
maternelle et infantile au 02 62 900 3
324 1903 118 pour avoir plus de
renseignements ou rendez vous sur le
site du département rubrique enfance
assistant familial
[Musique]